Speaker 1: There's been a headline floating
around over the last 24 hours that Republican
Senator Ted Cruz defended, giving Nazi salutes at
school board meetings. Now, that's not true. I'm
going to tell you right now that is not actually
what Ted Cruz did. What Ted Cruz did is horrible,
and I'm going to play it for you. But it would not
be accurate that Ted Cruz defends Nazi salutes.
What Ted Cruz did defend is the fact that parents
doing Nazi salutes at school board meetings
is protected by the First Amendment. Now, I
think it was still very stupid to do. And it also
is theoretically something which could lead to
an investigation depending on circumstances,
but that's actually kind of a second or third
layer. So let's talk about what what's going
on. The Daily Beast Beast headline is Ted Cruz
defends parents doing Nazi salutes at school
board meetings. Maybe. Yeah, I mean, he certainly
doesn't defend the salute. OK. During a fiery
Senate Judiciary Committee on Wednesday hearing on
Wednesday, Ted Cruz at one point defended parents
throwing up Nazi salutes at school. School board
meetings as protected by the First Amendment. OK?
Cruz, along with other Republicans, lambasted
Attorney General Merrick Garland for directing
the Justice Department to investigate the rise in
violent threats against educators. Now remember,
the National School Board Association is the
organization that asked that the school board
protests at least be considered under the
guise of domestic terrorism. That was not
what the Department of Justice, FBI or Merrick
Garland asked. They were asked to do that,
and that's really, really important.
So we're going to play the clip and
we'll talk about the implications and
different things here. So but listen very
carefully to the language that's being used.
Speaker 6: I did a quick count just sitting
here. During this hearing, I counted 20
incidents cited. Of the twenty fifteen on
their face are nonviolent. They involve things
like insults, they involve a Nazi salute.
That's one of the examples. My God, a parent did a
Nazi salute at a school board because they thought
the policies were oppressive. General Garland is
doing a Nazi salute. An elected official. Is that
protected by the First Amendment? Yes, it is. OK.
Speaker 1: So. I think we should be careful with
our language, and so all the headlines saying
Ted Cruz defends or supports Nazi salutes.
He's doing something horrible in this clip, but
he's not actually doing that. What Ted Cruz is
saying is, first of all, a Nazi salute is speech
protected by the First Amendment. That's true.
Now, the First Amendment doesn't insulate
you from the repercussions to that speech. So
Cruz is correct, saying that a Nazi salute
is protected speech, and Garland agreed.
That's not actually the controversy. That's a fake
part of the controversy. No one is saying a Nazi
salute is not protected by the First Amendment.
But Cruz is using all of this to go to this idea
that Merrick Garland told the Department
of Justice to investigate parents doing
Nazi salutes as domestic terrorists. That's number
one. Not true. And number two, it's a red herring.
Merrick Garland correctly explains. Later in this
hearing, the National School Board Association
wrote us a memo saying Consider whether some
of these actions at school board meetings by
parents are domestic terrorism. That's what the
National School Board Association asked to have
happen. It was not something Merrick Garland
directed, but let's go to the next and maybe
more interesting thing just because something
is protected speech doesn't mean it can't be
grounds for an investigation. It's, you know,
imagine that I say at a school board meeting,
I've got a dead body in my basement. OK, just
just to come up with something and then I leave.
My what I said is, I guess, protected by the
First Amendment, in other words, state run school,
I'm allowed to speak, the school can't censor me,
whatever. But you could still then hear what I
said and say, Oh wow, we've got to now investigate
you because of the content of what you said.
I was able to speak. My ability to
speak was not curtailed by the school,
which I guess you could say is state government.
But what I said can still have consequences.
And along the same lines, without getting into
the specifics of a Nazi salute or whatever
the things that parents say at school board
meetings could be used as the basis for
investigations, whether it's investigations into
domestic terrorism, whether apparent in talking
about, you know, I'm against masks, like I slap my
kid around at home when they do something wrong,
but I'm not going to put a mask on. Well,
protective services could hear that and say,
OK, you were allowed to say your piece, but
we now we're going to use the content of what
you said to launch an investigation because
you're saying you're smacking your kid around.
So these are like two or three or four different
issues. The lessons here are maybe not good to
use. Nazi salutes have examples of things that
should be defended no matter what. You know,
maybe Ted Cruz can pick other examples and
make sure to look at the video, because really,
I think it's an exaggeration to say Ted Cruz
defended the salute. He was trying to make a point
about its protection under the First Amendment,
about which he is right. And then he goes into
all sorts of other things that don't make sense.
Let me know your thoughts about the segment.